hello and welcome to the Sheehy science
show and so in this video I'm going to
finally go through and discuss the book
why we sleep written by Matthew Walker
and so in this video I'll give an
overview of the key points to take away
from the book and also my opinions on it
the good and bad sides to this book
because although overall I found the
book very captivating and engaging to
read but possibly one of the best
entries to a nonfiction book I've ever
read there's a couple of articles that
states that the book is actually filled
with errors and so we'll come on to that
a little bit later but firstly let's
just talk a bit about Matt Walker who is
he well he's a British scientist he was
born in Liverpool and then studied at
Nottingham before going across to the
States where he's currently professor of
neuroscience and psychology and director
of the sleep and neuroimaging laboratory
at the University of California Berkeley
not Harvard as I've written and see some
research and sleep for 20 years now and
this is his first book and the book is
structured into four different parts the
first one is talking generically about
what it is sleep then he talks about
sleep deprivation and the consequences
of having a poor night's sleep
part three talks about dreams and then
the last part of the book talks about
sleep disorders non drug therapies of
how to improve sleep and also the
feature of sleep so I have already
published a video talking about the
future of sleep so I will highlight the
other key areas of the book in this
video and go through what I think are
the key take-home messages in each
chapter so the title of the book is why
we sleep so well by Dewey so this
question has been puzzled by many and
can be summarized very well in this
crate if sleep does not serve an
absolutely vital function then is the
biggest mistake the evolutionary process
has ever made and so this comes off the
back pads while you're sleeping you
haven't got the time to get food to say
slice to find a mate to refugees and
you're also vulnerable to predation and
say different theories as to why we
sleep have a reasonable time from
logical ones such as to be have time to
conserve energy so in
one's about opportunity for eyeball
oxygenation Terry no that's about two
psychoanalytic ideas that it's an
unconscious state in which we fulfill
repressed wishes so now that I've read
this book can I answer this question
well if I have to give a full wide
summary to why we sleep I would have to
say it keeps us live so what actually is
sleep then well the key thing to know is
that sleep isn't just the absence of
being awake it's actually a very active
state so what causes us to enter this
sleep state well there are two key
factors involved in making us sleep and
that is a sleek drive and it's alignment
with your circadian rhythm so throughout
their 24 hours day when you're awake
your sleep Drive will increase and when
you go to sleep that drive will decline
because you're sleeping and that it's in
alignment with the circadian rhythm that
is your 24-hour fluctuations in
metabolic and cellular patterns of
activity so sleep drive sounds a little
bit abstract so what actually underpins
this drive to sleep so it's often
thought that this component is melatonin
and that melatonin generates sleep but
actually melatonin is better thought of
as regulating the onset of sleep so to
give an analogy it's like a race where
sleep is the race itself and melatonin
would be the timing official which
sounds the gun saying it's sleep time
but doesn't actually take part in the
race itself instead the molecule behind
the sleep drive is adenosine so
adenosine is a chemical and the levels
of adenosine rise during the daytime
when you're awake and they decline when
you sleep and so the interesting thing
about Denison is that its structure is
very similar to caffeine which who knows
and our beloved coffee and so the reason
that having a glass of coffee really
helps to keep your week is that caffeine
competes with a receptor that adenosine
would bind to you and so when it
competes for binding to this receptor
it prevents the action of adenosine the
problem though is that caffeine has a
half-life of five to seven hours so
depending on when you last had a cup of
coffee it can prevent you from
initiating and generating sleep and in
case you didn't know caffeine's also
found in decaf coffee just obviously at
much lower levels and now on to one of
my all-time favorite studies why they
gave caffeine to a spider and then they
looked at the impact on the spider's web
and so obviously as you can see caffeine
there's quite a dramatic impact on that
web but anyway what I love about the
study is just how short and sweet it is
I think more study should be like this
however this is one of the few studies
that's Matthew actually cites in this
book which is one of my problems that I
do have with this book is the general
lack of citations which is links to the
research papers where the facts are and
so also we'll come back to this again a
little bit later but continuing with
what is sleep sleep has different stages
and these can be broken down well into
multiple stages into REM sleep which is
rapid eye movement sleep and non REM
sleep which can be father's little
lights
it's intermediate and deep sleep so why
are there different states what's
actually going on well you can record
the brain waves during these different
stages and if you compare the brain
waves you can see that when your wake is
very different when you're undergoing
deep and REM sleep interestingly the
brain waves during a week also looks
very similar though to REM sleep however
different things are happening in each
of these different stages so according
to the book deep and REM sleep dominates
earlier during the night time and has a
role in synaptic pruning and memory
storage
whereas REM sleep dominates the later
part of sleep so the morning and is when
your body's in that paralyzed state so
when you're your limp and it's also the
stage where you dream so so really
crudely summarize what these different
states are awake can be considered
reception when you witness all these
different environmental sensations seep
and REM sleep is reflection where you
have memory storage and
can strengthen these new facts and
skills and REM sleep can be summarized
as integration by you interconnect new
with previous experiences building a
more accurate model of how the world
works so that's been a very generic
overview to brought sleep is but as
humans we are not the only species that
sleep and say different animals also
sleep and there's very interesting
differences across the animal kingdom
so firstly let's look at dolphins and
whales that do you think really awesome
which is to have half of the brain
sleeping at once otherwise known as you
me hmmm Easter and communicate myself
sleep also it took me ages to draw that
whale but they are not alone in this uni
hemispheric sleep also
birds can do it as well and that can be
useful especially in flocks of birds
when they've got to keep flying and say
they can have the birds on the outside
seizing this type of sleep so they have
this panoramic vision the whole time
apparently we humans have to some extent
the ability to do this as well but
obviously not to the same extent so
that's how they sleep can differ across
the kingdom also duration of sleep
differs very much so elephants
apparently sleep for hours and brown
bats need 19 hours of sleep a day and
then the pattern of sleep can also eat
very and so we would be considered money
phasic sleepers because we sleep while
he's made the sleep once during the
nighttime but some people also nap in
the afternoon and on today by Facebook
sleep and so this article talks about
this island in Greece could I Korea I
think I'm saying it right and according
to the book and mentioned in this
article as well there nothing is thought
to be contributing to the fact that this
island is often referred to as the
island of long life but obviously there
are other factors in fall so that as
well so moving on to the next chapter of
the book is looking at sleep deprivation
so an opposite way of thinking about
this is to look at the benefits of
having a full night sleep so
Walker mentions a lotta Mossberg
sleeping is very important for memory
formation and that is bathe before and
also after the learning process because
what happens when you sleep as these
memories get transferred from the
short-term location which is the
hippocampus region of the brain to the
long-term storage in the cortex
ironically sleeping is also thought to
be good for forgetting and so walk at
the scribes and experiments in the book
that they had some participants memorize
words and to each words they told them
whether or not they should remember that
word or to forget it the following time
when they test the participants they
instead of getting them to only remember
the ones they were told to remember they
were told to remember all of the words
and what they found was the words that
they were told to remember they
remembered better than the ones that
they were told to forget I hope that
made some sense
and then lastly sleep is also thought to
be good for skill so Walker jokes and
the phrase that we often say practice
makes perfect but instead maybe we
should be saying practice which sleep
makes perfect and this time instead of a
study we got a story and he describes
how he wants Matt's a
distinguished-looking gentleman he was
practicing a piece until late in the
evening so I think this is a piane piece
and he just couldn't seem to master it
but then the next morning he says I can
just play anyway besides perfecting a
skill also performing that school is
also thought to benefit from a good
night's sleep and so another example
given is Usain Bolt who is known to take
naps before breaking the world record
and so this make sure you rethink the
phrase snooze you lose
maybe instead we should be saying if he
don't sneeze you lose well if I were to
same thought I probably would lose even
if I could sleep anyway what happens
then if you are sleep deprived what are
the possible consequences so first I'm
sort of highlighted these are
correlations and as I said a lot of this
work is uncited and so I haven't
probably listened to it myself and so
much is just describing what
than record in the book and say take
this with a pinch of salt anyway the
first correlation that Walker talks
about is neural degeneration and he
describes wakefulness as being low-level
brain damage and I should have a
previous video where I talk more about
outside Miss disease and the lymphatic
system that I'll link for you here
because it's video things so long
secondly he talks about the correlation
of poor cardiovascular system and an
increased risk of heart attacks and
strokes due to an increased in blood
blood pressure by having a lot of sleep
then he talks about metabolism diabetes
and weight gain again I will say today
today like a couple of weeks ago which
I'll refer you to because yeah it's
getting quite anomalous video then there
is the reproductive system where
correlations have been shamed between
men who sleep less and have lower
testosterone levels and if it couldn't
get worse having less sleep also makes
you more vulnerable to catching colds so
all in all you could say that short
sleep predicts all cause mortality so
now let's talk about something a bit
more uplifting I move on to part three
of the book which is dreams so as I said
earlier in this video
dream sleep occurs during the REM phase
of sleep and if you look at the brain
activity during the dream sleep there
are four key areas of the brain that has
shown a spike in activity the first one
of these is the emotional centers of the
brain secondly it's the visual spatial
areas which deal with complex visual
perception then as the motor cortex
which deals with movements and then also
the hippocampus is active which is where
we talked about having the short-term
fat storage but what I think is a much
more interesting question is is there
actually a function of dreaming well
Walker suggests that there are actually
two functions of dreaming the first one
being improving emotional and mental
health and the second benefits being
related to problem solving and
creativity so regarding the national
mental health during REM sleep the brain
becomes the void of noradrenaline which
is the equivalent is the brain
equivalent of adrenaline and is a
stressful
hormone so this may explain why those
who are sleep-deprived have higher blood
pressure because adrenalin stimulates
that fight-or-flight response and then
there is the problem solving and
creativity so I don't if this is common
knowledge but Paul McCartney originated
the songs yesterday and let it be in his
sleep and so I've got a quote here that
says I wake up with a lovely tune in my
head I thought that's great I wonder
what that is
there was an upright piano next to me so
the right of the beds by the window I
got out of bed sat at the piano found G
sound F sharp minor seventh and that
leads he 3 then to B to E minor and
finally back to E it's all leads forward
logically I liked the melody a lot but
because I dreamed it
I couldn't believe I'd written it I
thought no I've never written anything
like this before but I had which was the
most magic thing and so having read the
book I saw don't think it's fully named
how this is a clear cause but during the
stage of sleep you somehow build
connections between distantly related
informational elements and that's the
current the equivalent of the difference
between knowledge which is retention of
facts and wisdom which is knowing what
the facts mean together maybe will
understand this battle with the
development of brain machine interfaces
which we could see in the future a
terrible plug about to you in my
previous videos anyway now let's look at
the last chapter of the book and I'm
gonna cut this a bit short as well I'm
just focused on one sleep disorder which
is most prevalent at least I think it is
and the two most common triggers being
emotional concerns and worry and
emotional distress and anxiety would
then be preventing sleep and so in the
fast-paced world that we do live in one
of the few times that we actually stop
information consumption and actually
inwardly reflect is when were in bed
trying to sleep and so what are some
steps that you can take to try and
improve your sleep onset so Walker
describes a number of tips at the end of
the book which I'll just list out here
so these include sticking to a sleep
schedule and
it's regularly sleeping and waking at
the same time each day
to not exercise to close the bedtime and
to try and avoid caffeine sideways and
nicotine and also so avoid alcoholic
drinks for for beds so I can drink in
the morning anyway another tip is to
avoid large meals and beverages before
beds
partly because large meals can cause
indigestion I'm drinking too much can
make you need a week and actually a week
during the night which isn't good as you
end up disrupting your sleep another tip
is to avoid naps after 3 p.m. and to
also try and relax before beds and to
have a hot bath to lower your body
temperature and another really important
thing especially with our phones and
laptops these days is to try and keep
your bedroom dark and to avoid looking
at your phones within the 30 minutes
before beds and you also get the white
sunlight exposure during the day which
is easier said than done but their
importance is to try and get more bright
light during the stuff in the morning as
opposed to the afternoon and all in all
if you are lying in bed awake get up and
do something until you feel tired again
so that really was a complete waste
through this book which isn't that big
but it's got flexible tax well there's a
lot of information in it but anyway now
on to my thoughts on the book so as I
mentioned before there's these very long
articles that describe all of the errors
that have been made in this book and so
obviously I haven't like I said there
isn't many citations so it's hard for me
to check any of the facts and I would
take too much time for me to go for it
as well but what I will say is that it
definitely is wrong to have errors in a
book especially if it could be
misleading to the reader but I think all
in all this general topic area there is
a very much a lack of knowledge and
understanding how the brain changes
during sleep and what the underpinning
processes are and I think that there's
just so much we don't understand and
that's why you know you can look at
these studies and see these correlations
but until it's been further studied
everything in this book is a little bit
wibbly-wobbly
but from reading this I can say that I
do appreciate sleep more than I did
before and I do very much enjoy a good
night's sleep
and on that note I hope you enjoyed the
video and thanks for listening